[音楽]
re 品
voodoo
初心
こんにちは
東北大学東北アジア研究センター教授のアシカ
です
環境科学研究科でも兼任教授をしています
今日は皆さんに
温暖化問題エネルギー問題について呼ばれし
します
なんとなくその学科 a 問題だか対策
日本は頑張っているという風に
なイメージを持っている人が多いと思うんですけれどいや実はそんなことはなくて
まだまだ
やんなきゃいけないことがたくさんありますよ姓と駅前ですよということをメッセージ
として伝えたいですっ
最初にですねあのー
まぁ今までどんな
感じで日本なり世界がこの問題について対応してきたからについて
方にお話しします
最初にこの今日一番上が原発なんですけど
ご存じのようにスリーマイル事故があって攻めの部分や事故があって残念なこと
2011年に
まあ福島第1原発事故がありました
レオン欄から a 対策という意味では90年代から絵も落下対策をする必要がある
声は高まって英国15
米ハーゲンは決裂したんですが多く21でバリ協定がようやく
採択されたという事です日本で再生
軍医は聞いて原発の事故まではあまり
普及していなかったですですがそのエコまあ
アクセルとブレーキアクセルの政策がそういう形に効果を持って
日本でも普及し始めています同時に電力システム改革
今まで日本はご存知常に
東京関東だったら東京電力トークだったら遠く面力がまあある意味では独占していたん
ですがメンバーは
誰でもデッキを作って誰でも触れるようではなって
ですがまだまだ自由化は途中でして8割のマーケットはいわゆる大手電力が握っている
という状況です
米さあ絵省エネ ne 整備に関しては日本は黄色以降
すごく運張ったアーマー他の国も頑張ってはいるんですえーどう
実は売りショック以降90年飛行はですね
多いショックの後位はすごく頑張ったんですが旧準備高は
照明も実は警戒しているという状況
です
で a
まあ温暖化対策エネルギー対策を考えるともいいじゃあ2030年
これから10年ですけどどういうような電力を覆って使うか供給して
消費するかということを考える必要があります
これは日本政府が
まあ公式に決めている目標としている
エネルギーミックス2030年ってどういう電力がどれだけあるかということを示して
います
でへまあ誰でも大歓です誰も買うというかまだこのゆっくりあっていう風にあるんです
がこれがまあ
20から22%というのを目標にしています
でこれも誰でもわかると思うんですが
これをかなり再稼働を進めて a
前田したらしい雪の電波つも詰めていけないという数値なので
台もできるとは思ってはいい
a ですがこの数字が大きいから
再生可能エネの数字がちっちゃくなっていますしいろんな問題があると言う
ですナム貞子今
来年の改定に向けてエネルギー今日は各この数字をどうするかというのが日本で大きな
議論をこれから大きな下呂
になる
予定です
じゃあ世界は日本をどう見ているかということについてお話したいと思います
まあこのテーマがこのセミナーのテーマが
まあ日本の日
飛ぶっていう昼ひどい昼一部ということはよく内閣
言い方が良くないかも知れませんけど意外に知られてないことまた5階
またはシーンはどういうのが a テーマだと思います
日本は温暖化対策なんとなく頑張っていると日本国民は多くが思っている
桃
んですが実はそんなことはなくて
これはですね進むせと思いますねぇー
を呼びますけれど得にが同程度お腹対策頑張っているかということを示しています
で58か国中まあ日本はいつも下から数えた方が早い
孫ば別科10番目具合したからです
店10%安念は下から2番目でした
なので実は世界は日本は歌化対策すごく奥へている国だというふうに認識しています
これも同じようならーキングなんです今日かなんですけどまぁ
石炭をどれだけ止めているかと言う
評価国評価なんですが日本は一番下なので日本は一番石炭をまだまだ使っている
これ選手国の中ですんですけど漆黒
の中では一番石炭王までまだ使っている国これからも使おうとしている組だ
という風に共感されております
でなんでそうなっているかというとまあ単純な話でして
セクターから課税衝動どんどん作っています
先進国でこれだけせキター火力発電所を作っている国は日本だけですここまずは日本を
どこにどういう
てきたからパチュレーショガーというその状況
がどうなっているかと言うを支持しているんですが赤が
も既に動いちゃっている
20期もし下に
まあ建設されて動いてますこれは2012年以降の建設が始まった
のでして絶対で50くらい2012目以降建設また計画があって早朝
印象は持た蹴られて動いてしまっているという状況です
じゃあこういう状況に対して何をするべきか
まあもちろんいろんな人の間が入っているような考えがあるのですが
まぁあのー着色人的はええまあ震災を経て事故を経て日本はなる独原発は使えない
セクターも使わないそう
いう社会になった方がいい
いいということで研究者としてじゃあ
というようなエネルギーをどういう風に使えばいいか
so 時に
まぁ実際も台がを切らない起きないか問題というのはば
それが需要供給のバランスが崩れて電気は退学なるとかすごくコストがかかるとかねき
だがすごく高くなるとか
そんなことをいろいろ研究しています
でその時にまああの研究者と一緒に今ケアしているのが原発ゼロエネルギー喧嘩
戦略です
ねそうについてちょっと簡単に紹介します
これが a 私たちのまあ2030年2050年
どういう霊力構成になっているかということを示して5でして
まああの右から
2番目の2030年の時には黒クロは
すいません
石炭なんですけど
それがなくなっているでまぁそういうのをもう使わない
伊勢30年でも育ち生姦酷だと
えぎ声50年は
天然ガスも束ねてんぜがしか実はピンクでまだ2030年時点ではが起こっているん
ですがそれを吐くそれも使えない
それがそういう社会が本当に達成できると
でその時に問題いわゆる経済的な問題とか
電気が足りなくなる問題とかそういうのかないですよという具体的なシナリオを書いて
提案してまー多くの人に納得してもらってできれば
ようのえる
制作 n 液胞計画を変えることができればいいなと思っています
じゃあもうちょっと a
具体的に話をしますとまあ今
今までそのエネルギーを供給再編がこれだけとか
原発これだけ石炭火力はこれだけっていう話をしたんですが
日本で実は一番欠けているのは省エネです
冒頭に90年以降止まってしまった通って
一音が停滞してしまうという申し上げたんですが
本当にですねあの今いろんなポテンシャルが省へ米であります
例えば5年10年短いものは3年で元がとれてその後どんどんもお金が儲かるのに最初
のまあ他で大原はね払うのがちょっとお空だ
躊躇するということで省エネのポテンシャルがどんどん&
失われてしまっていますで省エネをすればある意味でさえも
原発もいらないもうちょっと極端な言い方ですけど
照明をどれだけ平出学科によって生産10年2050年
遠い集社会になるかっては実は決まります
なので脱原発原発やだと思うのであれば省エネがまず重要ですし逆に重賞へでは儲かる
話だということを理解していただければと思います
でちょっとその省エネどう守るかという話なんですけどこれは2050年までに省エネ
なり再エネに投資を
吸うときだいたいそれがいくらぐらいかかるかっていうのとそれによってどれだけいい
ことがあるか
左側の長い棒は
いわゆる以降月火木行也
個人の家系でも光熱費払ってるんですがそれがどれだけ節約されるかという数字でして
右に比べると投資に比べて儲かる
そこ月削減の方が大きいということを示しています
どういうことかというと日本は毎年で10兆円
海外からかチェス化石燃料を輸入しています
でその分の毎年20兆円のブーが国内電話あることになるので日本経済にとっては必ず
プラスでになります
6なんか対策は経済にマイナスになる所ですねまぁ質量はすごく増える
とかそういうネガティブなイメージを
持ってる日が多いと思うんですけど実はそうそうじゃなくて
温暖化対策をした方が得日本みたいに化石燃料を輸入している国は温暖化では飛行した
方が経済にとってプラスになります
なのでまぁあのこういうことを言うとあそうなんだというふうに思う人も多いですが
なんとなく
まあ温暖化対策は経営者にマイナス後は脱原発も経済にマイナスになっていると思って
いる人が多いのが幻聴だと思います
めちゃもう一つはいどーまあそういう
て来たーー0原発ゼロの話をすると本当にあの
丁寧にならないんですかということを聞く人が非常に多いです
これもなんとなくまあ結髪が止まってしまうと
力が高く食べなくなるとで足りなくなると
エマ電気代がすごく高くなるというふうなふうに思っている人がいるんですが実際そう
なことではなくて幻聴でも実は日本は電力設備は非常にはまっています
でかつ電力をできることを考えるときに別居本当に使う時間っていうのはなる季節が
限られているんですね
でかつ再生可能エネルギーが早く使えないという人がいるんですけど
再生可能エネルギーが支えラルクなる季節とか時間っていうのも限られている
どういうことかというと例えば太陽光が使えなくなるのは夏戸
いう形があるんですねその時今重要大きくなるとか
夏の夕方にどういう風な対策をすればいいかと
どういう大差が具体的にあるかその時にどういう
まあコストがかかって何が必要かそういうふうに細かく
議論していかなきゃいけないんですけどなんと9日本全体で電気
足りない生で原発必要だと席たから潮だというような議論し化されていないのが日本が
幻聴でして京急したしてそこを
変えなきゃいけないなと思っていますまさにこれはまあ部分あの時間帯によっては
a 厳しくなる時がありますけどその場合はこういう
電力を使って需要側の管理をするなり他のところか
冷気をとってくるとってくるいう頭してくるとかそういうことをする
エヴァ日本全体でも日本それぞれの各管区
北陸電力とか
四国電力そこは原発2隻たり非常に重要日
依存してるんですけどそういうところも大丈夫ですよということを示しています
で最後にですねまぁあのいろいろ a
やんなきゃエフェクトはたくさんあります
まあいろんなエネルギーミックスの決める
今年来年政府が決めるし
オーダー化対策の目標を決めると選挙もありますそういうことに関していろいろ天気所
して議論しなきゃいけないですし
皆さんも
ブーブーしていただければてぃ cars 流通アティロンえへ伊勢きゅん se さあ
月会
内緒でも無理そういういわゆる c はを具体的どう
議論していくかっていうのが大事です
最後にまあ
何ですかねなかなかそう簡単に社会を壁が難しいんですけど今どんな部分のばっか人が
声を上げているのでそういう人たちにも頑張っていきたいです
もらいたいですし我々もまあ
価格は9
おじさんおばさんですが一緒には返しはちと一緒にこの問題を議論して具体的な白松し
て具体的に日本を変える
世界を変えることができればなと思って
言いますので一緒にぜひ皆さんも一緒にがんばり頑張りましょう
今日はどうもありがとうございました